it's really great to be joined today by
chip parlez who is an investigative
journalist research analyst
photojournalist scholar and specialists
in right-wing movements and there is
just so much to talk about with him
today chip to begin with
you've been warning anybody who will
listen about the growing threat of
everything that falls under the militia
and Patriot movements as we sort of know
them for decades at this point talk to
us about how those groups first got on
your radar well actually it got on the
radar of some 30 people back in the
1970s who began to research under the
name public eye network and build a
national network of people looking at
what we couldn't figure out back then
before a lot of revelations about
right-wing activity and the FBI
COINTELPRO program we weren't sure if
the federal government was working with
with some of these right-wing groups and
so a group of people set up something
called the public eye magazine which is
now at political Research Associates and
we began to struggle over these issues
and do research and we discovered that
there was some symbiotic relationship
between the federal government and
right-wing groups but the right-wing
groups actually had their own reality
and and there were many different kinds
of right-wing groups so this scholar
named gene Hardesty who had been doing
research for the ACLU on the
anti-feminist women's movement and the
stop er a movement in the late 70s
she basically set up a think-tank where
people like me it could could be paid to
do this research and as well as
encouraging other people to network with
political Research Associates as it's
now called and so we set up basically a
watchdog network to look at this that
starts in the seventies really morphs
into political Research Associates in 81
and in 2000 2001 Matthew and lines and I
wrote a whole book called right-wing
populism in America with the tagline
that subtitle was
too close for comfort because we saw the
growing inequality in the u.s. feeding
into these right-wing groups and as long
as that growing inequality was really
hurting people these right rule groups
who were going to grow and that was our
prediction back then
well I'm sure that people can already
sort of anticipate the ways in which
this conversation will in part two of
the interview tomorrow lead into how
this is relevant today politically but
before we get into that can you first
talk to us about some of the commonly
shared characteristics that these
different groups often have in common
and I'm talking about you know
right-wing populist groups the patriot
movement armed militias white
supremacists etc some of that I've
identified and then I'll turn it over to
you to sort of expand correct or or or
add to this we have the the idea of the
government as an entity that could or
has turned tyrannical that we need to
defend ourselves from seems to be one
common motif of many of these groups
anti-semitism very very often a motif of
these groups and scapegoating in terms
of placing blame for our current
situations scapegoating of a variety of
groups those are three traits I've
identified absolutely true everything
you said is is spot-on
basically what you're looking at then is
a range of different right-wing groups
that go from the right wing of the
Republican Party on out to the Ku Klux
Klan and the neo-nazi movement but with
tremendous differentiation and
boundaries although they're porous
between these groups and so you would
start by saying this is an
overwhelmingly white Christian movement
but then I'll add I've interviewed
Jewish and black members of the militia
movement but in some states there are
militia groups that would not tolerate
having either a black person or a Jewish
person in their midst so it's
complicated and that's part of what the
research we've been doing tries to tease
out I would say that overwhelmingly
their talk with conspiracy theories
about secret elites running the
government
above and lazy sinful subversive people
down below who are picking the pockets
of the average hard-working white
American now you know there are elites
and and they're picking our pocket but
they're not secret we know who they are
and we both the Democrats and
Republicans choose to just keep sending
money up to them and pushing people down
the economic ladder so it's a good
reason a lot of these people are angry
there's a great new book by sociologist
Arlie Hochschild
called strangers in their own land which
talks about why they feel so ripped off
and so dishonored by the government and
a lot of their analysis is true but a
lot of the analysis blames people of
color Mexicans immigrants Muslims and
and they divert their anger from a
target that could change the economic
system to be more fair tour these
scapegoats and I'd say those that an
authoritarianism and in a sense that so
and in some of these groups drawing the
conclusion that if these people are in
fact a secret conspiracy and they're out
to destroy America and the Constitution
as we know it of why wait for them to
get us we have to go get them first and
and that you see happening now with the
attacks and all sorts of people who are
the named scapegoats which we can talk
about tomorrow chip can you talk a
little bit about different elements of
these movements have a sort of varying
proclivity towards violence to achieve
their goals some of these groups are
more known for using real-world violence
and some less so can you give us some
examples of sort of the range and which
groups might be on either end of the
spectrum
well it's interesting yet you can
obviously find out pretty easily that
some neo-nazi groups and some Klan
groups have traditionally engaged in
physical violence both individually and
on a mass scale the lynchings by the Ku
Klux Klan and its supporters throughout
the south starting in the 1800s after
the Civil War with the form a
of the Ku Klux Klan which met lions in
our book right-wing populism in America
identified as the first major social
movement form of right-wing populism in
the US so you look at that but I'm a
civil liberties advocate - so you have
to say there's methodology and there's
ideology and the ideology of these
groups doesn't automatically create a
propensity for violence in each
individual so some individuals in the
Klan would not become violent and some
individuals who are not neo-nazis would
not become violent but some do and so
trying to figure out how the government
deals with these threats of violence and
actual violence in a way that I know
this is going to be hard for some to
swallow doesn't viable right violate the
rights of people in these far-right
movements to have First Amendment rights
and that's that's the struggle between
what's First Amendment rights and what's
a threat of violence which is sanctioned
by laws there is an aspect to some more
academic writings on this issue
one such writing that you're quoted in
extensively which is waves of rancor by
Hillard and Keith which includes along
with many of the groups that we've been
talking about it also includes groups
that sometimes are seen by some although
I would sort of push back against this
as left-wing groups including the Nation
of Islam and even in in the way he
existed in the 1990s someone with the
views of sort of an Al Sharpton are
sometimes included under the group's the
types of groups we've been talking about
can you comment on that a little bit in
terms of the similarities and
differences to the groups we've been
talking about well I would argue that
while I'm not a fan of either the
rhetoric of the Nation of Islam about
Jews and white people and other people
that they fantasize about as being their
enemy or Sharpton who although you know
I gotta say now he said it turned into a
spokesperson for a lot of rational angry
thinking in the black community but I
don't think it
fair to suggest that they have an
organized plan for violence and you know
it's like the Black Panther Party if you
actually look at the violence that was
attributed to the Black Panther Party
almost entirely it was provoked by
government agencies that overreacted to
them carrying guns which in most
circumstances was completely illegal now
we see white people with guns pointed at
federal officials who don't get arrested
but we see black people with gun scene
is a terrific threat to us and by us I
mean the white community are black
people makes us shake and shiver we're
as armed white people is something that
you know well that's just them being
angry at the government so there's a
kind of a double standard there let's
pick it up there we've been speaking
with chip Burrell a we will continue
this conversation tomorrow
we're continuing our conversation with
chip Burrell a he's an investigative
journalist research analyst
photojournalist scholar and specialist
in right wing movements and conspiracy
theories chip yesterday we sort of
started to lay the groundwork for the
different types of groups that you've
been following closely at this point for
decades
let's contextualize this in what's going
on politically right now in the United
States and maybe one way to enter this
would be our discussions about whether
Donald Trump and his associates
personally are followers of either
anti-semitic alt-right extremists right
wing ideals is that a question
that is relevant in the sense that if
these groups are believing that Trump is
their guy I would argue it's actually
less important whether Donald Trump
personally believes any of their
rhetoric because they will be activated
in a way that would would not depend on
Donald Trump's truthful membership in
these groups but rather the perception
they're in am i do you agree with that
or do you think that there's a different
approach
no absolutely agree with that that's
again how I would analyze it yeah it
doesn't you know first of all the
argument similarly is is Donald Trump of
fascists or you know is the current
presidential regime fascist and I study
this you know I like to say Trump uses
fascistic rhetoric to mobilize a mass
base which has elements which are in
fact fascist and you look at all right
and Bannen whose chief aide and all
right includes fascists and and neo neo
fascists and neo-nazi so yeah it doesn't
matter whether Trump believes it or not
it doesn't matter whether he is
technically a fascist or just a vicious
right-wing populist who is racist sexist
you know and I submit it whatever and
xenophobic use all those things and the
problem is what happens to a democracy
when people are so cynical and so angry
at the care
of the liberal left and the democratic
party that the entire constitutional
system could break down now that sounds
pretty far out there but there's a great
online resource from Professor
bookbinder it's at the Facing History
and ourselves website that's and we're
bookbinder says there was a period
before Hitler took power called the vie
Mar period when society was losing its
equilibrium that it was fragile he talks
about the fragility of democracy and
there were moments that the rise of
Hitler could have been stopped by a kind
of mass base of rebellion against the
regime in would not meaning a violent
one but just you know basically stopping
what was going on in uniting to build a
common defense of democracy and that
failed and it failed because people kept
saying oh he doesn't believe that Hitler
doesn't believe it and once he's in
office he'll be under control of all
these sensible people well that's what
they say about Trump and the Republicans
and you're starting to see some
Republicans wake up to the fact that
Trump is a very dangerous
anti-democratic small D tyrant and
authoritarian and narcissist is it is it
can we stop this I certainly hope so I'm
certainly working with people trying to
but it doesn't matter how you construct
Trump I wrote an essay a couple of years
ago called heroes know which villains to
kill and it has to do with how rhetoric
can prompt people to act on their own to
commit violence against the name scape
those we saw at Rwanda we saw it in
Serbia we saw in every genocide in
history from their minions to the nachi
genocide to Cambodia to all genocide
start with this framework of a demagogue
saying those people are undermining our
very existence as a people but the
people are defined narrowly and the
rhetoric suggest again that we need to
get them before they get us we're
actually going to be interviewing later
this week professor James Whitman who
has a new book
which sort of loosely addresses some of
the similarities now compared to
pre-world War two Germany and I think
it's gonna be an interesting
conversation let me play devil's
advocate with you for a second okay so
there are some who will here are
conversational let's say you know David
let's let's grant that you guys are
correct there it doesn't matter what
Trump's personal views are Donald Trump
is indeed garnering the support of some
of these extremist groups however we do
have freedom of the press we have an
established history in this country
where we could not possibly become
anything like the authoritarian dystopia
that some are sort of warning of can you
give us some specific ways in which an
administration could if they wanted to
push us in that direction in terms of
legislation and more than just rhetoric
I guess is what I'm asking what could be
done by an administration well they're
already trying to do it and they've
already started doing it they've have a
press relationship where they have
demonized any voice that is critical of
the government and of Trump and so
that's where it begins it begins by
silencing the press and you don't need a
lot of silence the press you can simply
pick the people you want to talk to on
TV who are already part of the project
of tearing down civil society in this
country because they're afraid that
there's a secret conspiracy of liberals
to create big government which leads to
totalitarianism and totalitarianism was
Hitler and Stalin and that's why you
know during the Obama first campaign you
saw a sign saying Obama's both Hitler
and Stalin that was the thesis of the
economic advisors to this entire
movement von Mises and Hayek and Milton
Friedman they think that big government
leads to totalitarianism and the
terrible fact is Trump would impose a
form of totalitarianism without having
been legislated at all what are ways in
which this can be fought against a
I'll just say it's sort of an in the
plainest most broad way what can the
average person do given these tendencies
that we've identified and the groups
that are being catalyzed by the
presidency of Trump what can the average
person do talk to their neighbors talk
to their co-workers join local groups I
think this is going to be stopped by
building local broad-based groups that
span the political spectrum consisting
of people who know that this is a
dangerous moment they've read history
they understand what Trump is doing and
they can push the elected officials in
their states including the one sent to
Washington to just say no to break from
this regime and you do that by listening
to their fears and their concerns and
their complaints and their grievances as
well and you find common language and
common ground I mean right now I talk
about the Democrats and the Republicans
is the two Stooges of the wealthy well
you know a lot of people think of the
Three Stooges so I try to get people to
think of the Democrats and Republicans
as like the three students now you don't
know what to do and so we got a
organized as a plurality to change this
is there a there a particular is there a
particular area where you know work work
trying to stay on top of constant news
in so many different areas we've got
pipelines being proposed that would be
hugely damaging to the environment and
benefiting foreign companies like
Keystone XL
we've got net neutrality provisions
being rolled back and you know a Senate
set the Senate recently voted to allow
ISPs to sell your browsing history to
advertisers meanwhile we've got you know
the Affordable Care Act American Health
Care Act ibaka that's going on is there
a particular area of legislation that
most relates in your mind took the risk
of a presidency that is supported by
these types of right-wing groups well I
gotta tell you I don't follow
legislation as much as I follow ideology
and social so I would argue that right
now you can think about legislation but
it's the action
in the streets and in your neighborhoods
that's gonna change things and I say you
know I understand people have family and
work obligations but I would sit in
elected officials office if they're not
paying attention
I believe in nonviolent civil
disobedience I think it has come to that
I think it's well past the time we can
depend on the Republicans and the
Democrats to save us democracy will save
us if we take take it seriously chip in
the limited time we have left I do want
to touch on another area that you've
spoken about extensively which is
conspiracy theories without talking
about any specific conspiracy theory
I've had the idea for years that part of
what makes conspiracy theories appealing
to some is the idea that it's far more
scary to believe that really serious
aspects of our of our lives are
unpredictable right and that horribly
unpredictable horrible unpredictable
things can happen there are some who are
would feel better about believing that
there was some evil conspiracy and that
some of the terrible things that happen
in the world are planned and not random
what do you think about that is there
some aspect of that in terms of what
makes conspiracy theories catch on many
times well it's what you said remember
that there are conspiracies history is
not based on conspiracy history is based
on powerful horses in contests with each
other for the shape of how a nation is
going to be operated and and the world
system so yeah
bad things happen sometimes they're
pretty random sometimes you can't really
as an investigative reporter
I spend months sometimes on a story I
can't figure it out there's no there
there that I can really nail down when
that happens I say walk away when other
people get to that point they start to
imagine and create and spread these
conspiracy theories about what really
happened even though they don't have any
facts that three people who had any kind
of brains could could track down there's
no there there there's no fact-finding
there's just allegations
we've been speaking
chip Burrell a chip it's been so great
speaking to you I really really
appreciate you taking the time to talk
to us thank you so much